I think it's commonplace how the face is
of a triangle if we know the length of the base
and its height.
So, for example, if this is my triangle, this length is here
here - the base - is of length b, and the height here is
with the length h, it is easy to guess that the face of
this triangle will be equal to 1/2 on the base
the height.
For example, if the base is equal to 5, and the height
is equal to 6, then the face will be 1/2 by 5 by 6,
which is 1/2 at 30 - which is equal to 15.
Now, what is not so well-known is how the person's face is
triangle when the sides of the triangle are given
When the height is not given.
For example, how is a triangle located,
where only the lengths of the parties are given.
Let's say that this is country a, country b and country s. A, b and c are
the lengths of these countries.
How did we find this?
To do this we will apply something that
is called the Heron formula.
I will not prove it in this video.
I'll prove it in another video.
In fact, to prove this, I probably have
the necessary tools.
In fact, it is simply the Pythagorean theorem
still quite algebra.
But I will show you the formula now and how
it is applied, then I hope you see it is
quite simple and easy to remember.
It can be a nice trick to impress someone.
Thus, according to the Heron formula, we first find the third variable
S, which is actually the perimeter of this one
triangle divided by 2.
plus plus b plus divided by 2.
Then, once you find S, the face of the triangle - this one
triangle here - will be equal to the square root of
S - this variable S here, which we have just found--
multiplied by S minus 'a' by S minus b, by S minus by.
This is the Heron formula here.
This combination.
I will enclose it to make it clearer.
So here's the Heron formula.
If that looks a little complicated - a little bit
it's really, really, a mere 1/2 on the base
the height.
Let's try one or two concrete examples and yes
we actually see that this is not so bad.
Let's say I have a triangle.
Let's leave the formula here.
Let's say I have a triangle with sides
with lengths 9, 11 and 16.
Apply the Heron formula.
S in this situation will be the perimeter divided by 2.
So 9 plus 11 plus 16 divided by 2.
Which is equal to 9 plus 11 - is 20 - plus 16 is
36 divided by 2 is 18.
And then the face of the Heron formula will be equal to
square root of S, which is 18, multiplied by S minus a, which is S minus 9.
18 minus 9 multiplied by 18 minus 11 by 18 minus 16.
18 minus 9 by 18 minus 11 by 18 minus 16 minutes.
Then it is equal to a square root of 18
9 at 7 in 2.
Which is equal to-- let's see, 2 by 18 is 36.
I will regroup it a little.
This is equal to a square root of 36 by 9 by 7,
which is equal to a square root of 36 per square
root of 9 per square root of 7.
The square root of 36 is 6.
It's just 3.
We do not have negative square roots,
because there are no negative lengths of the parties.
This will be equal to 18 at
square root of 7.
So just that, you saw it only took it
a few minutes for applying the Genoa formula and even less than
this to find that face of this triangle
here is equal to 18 square root of seven.
Anyway, I hope it has become clear to you.